estamos en el inciso c que dice evalúa
la integral definida de 0 a 10
dh prima de tdt usando las unidades
correctas y explicando el contexto de
esta expresión en este problema entonces
la integral definida de 0 a 10 de h
prima de tdt pues ésta es muy fácil de
hacer por el teorema fundamental del
cálculo dice si tenemos la derivada
adentro de una integral tenemos que
hacer solamente la resta de los límites
de evaluación o sea h de 10 - h de 0 y
50 h de 10 - h de 0 eso ya lo tenemos en
nuestra tabla más aún esto es lo que ha
cambiado de temperatura mit en el
transcurso de 10 minutos
entonces h de 10 - h de 0 podemos decir
que es la diferencia de temperatura que
ha pasado al cambio de 10 minutos
después de 10 minutos y bueno nosotros
sabemos cuánto vale h de 10 de h de 0
solamente hay que hacer la resta aquí lo
tenemos la tabla h de 10 vall de 43 y h
de cero vale 66 entonces
43 menos 66 70 vale 66 iván cuantos 43
166 esto es lo mismo que 66 menos 43 que
es 23 con signo negativo es decir menos
23 grados celsius y las unidades son
grados celsius porque lo que estamos
midiendo es el cambio de temperatura la
diferencia de temperatura por lo tanto
ya tenemos el inciso sem
ahora vamos con el inciso de que dice en
el tiempo de igual a cero tenemos unas
galletas las cuales se han retirado de
un horno con una temperatura de 100
grados la temperatura de estas galletas
en el tiempo te está modelada por la
función diferenciable de de la que se
sabe que ve prima de t es igual a menos
13.84 a la menos 0.17 3 step usando los
modelos dados al tiempo te iguala 10
segundos
qué diferencia de temperatura va a haber
entre las galletas y el té y bueno se me
ocurre que una buena forma de resolver
este inciso es utilizando la misma idea
que en el inciso anterior
carl la diferencia de temperatura y
después si yo tengo que mi temperatura
inicial son 100 grados
yo puedo restarle a 100 grados la
diferencia de temperatura que hubo de 0
a 10 minutos es lo mismo que hice en el
inciso pasado entonces vamos a hacerlo
se me ocurre que esto va a ser igual a
la integral de 0 a 10 db prima de prima
de tdt porque ya tengo la función de
prima de temp y para no resolver la
ecuación diferencial prefiero hacer esta
integral y bueno esto es muere una vida
muy parecida al inciso anterior por lo
tanto vamos a tratar de resolverlo b
prima de desigualdad menos 13.84 y al a
0.17 3 t entonces tenemos que hacer esta
integral
dt y bueno podemos hacer esta integral
directa esto es igual
bueno primero cuál es la derivada de la
a x si yo supiera la derivada de esto
que tengo aquí entonces ya casi acabé la
derivada con respecto a x de ea la x
pues es lo mismo que a por a la x esto
es por la regla de la cadena yo tengo
que hacer la derivada de lo que está acá
adentro que es am y ponerlo
multiplicando a la entonces usando esta
información la integral de a la x de x
va a ser lo mismo que uno entre a por la
x más una constante integración de hecho
estas dos expresiones te dicen lo mismo
por lo tanto ya puedo yo hacer esta
expresión que tengo aquí esto es lo
mismo que esta constante que es menos
13.84 dividido entre el número que está
acá arriba entre menos 0.1 73 entre
menos 0.17 3 ya esto multiplicarlo por
el a lo mismo te entonces solamente hay
que poner y repetir lo mismo
a la menos 0.17 3 t y esto evaluado
a 10 tenemos elementos de integración de
0 a 10 entonces vamos a hacerlo con
mucha más calma esto me va a quedar
déjenme poner esto otra vez igual aunque
yo sé que lo pueden hacer con la
calculadora pero vamos a ponerlo igual
menos 13.84 entre menos 0.17 3 ahorita
lo voy a resolver que multiplica a la
menos 0.1 73 por 10 que es menos 1.7 3
ya lo multiplique por diez y esto hay
que restarle la evaluación en cero que
es y al das
esta cosa por cero que es cero y es la
cero pues es uno entonces menos uno y
bueno ahora para resolver esto pues
ahora sí voy a utilizar la calculadora
vamos a sacar la calculadora y primero
antes de hacer cualquier cosas dejen de
empezar con esta parte de aquí entonces
yo tengo a en elevado a la menos 1.7 3
ya esto hay que restarle 1 y que me va a
dar esto es igual a menos punto 82 27
entonces menos 8.227 es todo lo que está
aquí ya esto hay que multiplicarlo por
la división de 13.84 entre 0 puntos 17
voy a cancelar de una vez los signos
porque pues menos entre menos nada más
entonces por 13.84 que está dividido
entre 0.17 3
y esto es igual am vamos a hacer una vez
igual am - 65.80 y 17 lo voy a redondear
menos 65 puntos 82 para no cargar con
todos estos números entonces ya tenemos
la respuesta de toda esta integral esta
integral es menos 65 punto 82 grados
celcius porque estamos midiendo el
cambio de la temperatura del tiempo te
iguala 0 al tiempo t igual a 10 pero
ahora nosotros sabemos que empezamos en
100 grados centígrados
entonces si esta es la diferencia de
temperatura habrá que restarle a 100
grados centígrados la diferencia de
temperatura que tenemos entonces
no perdón activos menos y esto es igual
a rangos no no no no aquí algo hice mal
no puede aumentar la temperatura está
disminuyendo la temperatura por lo tanto
perdón aquí hubo un error es 100
- 65 puntos 81 72 47 y los todos demás y
esto es igualdad 34 punto 18
entonces ya sé que me galletas al
transcurrir 10 minutos van a tener 34
puntos 18 grados y ahora sí ya podemos
comparar la cantidad de grados celsius
que tenía mi té con la cantidad de
grados que tienen mis galletas por lo
tanto 43 menos 34 pues es una cosa muy
sencilla 43 menos 34 a esto es igual a
8.81 por lo tanto ya acabé 8.82 grados
celsius va a ser la diferencia de
temperatura entre mis galletas y mi té
por lo tanto estas mis respuestas del
éxito de y hemos acabado el problema